well I'm not sure I would say it was an
unexpected Victory I think a lot of
people anticipated this I'm did you I I
did predict it and you can ask my
partner I went 100 pounds off of him
because of him should have tweeted but
um I think one of the big reasons that
this happened is because Hillary Clinton
was the candidate and I think she was
very much a flawed candidate she was
very much the presumptive incumbent in a
year that was not a year to be an
incumbent her message was very much a he
had Obama let's have it again Obama
mocked too and that message didn't
resonate with people who hadn't had the
recovery that they were expecting since
2008. so people were still about four
thousand dollars worse off than they
were before the Great Recession happened
people were frustrated they didn't see
that they had benefited from any of the
recovery and I think that was that
economic message that Donald Trump said
I'm going to create jobs is what pushed
him forward and is it your view that in
a way that was always true and baked in
early on and actually all the ups and
downs of the campaign and it was a very
dramatic campaign in September October
November the debates the revelations the
tapes in a way none of that made a
difference the mind was made up because
this was a change year it was definitely
a change here and I think you saw that
with the support that Bernie Sanders had
and particularly the support he had for
Millennials and and Hillary wasn't able
with particularly with Millennial women
she wasn't able to get that support that
they expected and they were really
looking at what are the policies in
their voting on policies and they're
saying I want to be able to pay my
student loans off I want to be able to
get a job I want to be able to advance
myself and they weren't seeing that
being possible under her so that's the
perspective of a republican who's fed
say was not a Donald Trump supporter
early on in the process what about you
Ted Malik you know we heard the theory
there that in a way it's mainly about
the divisions of Hillary Clinton is that
your explanation for why Donald Trump
won
well it's certainly one of the reasons I
think I take issue at the first uh with
the title of this whole debate calling
it a tragedy we've got the question mark
in there well I don't think it's a
question mark I don't think in a
Shakespearean year either is it a comedy
I think what Trump will prove that this
is very much a republican play
uh the pendulum has swung I mean this is
a pendulum year and it's really an
election of realignment so we've moved
from a blue country to a red country
except on the coast and I think that the
social science term to explain all this
uh bronstein and others have used it is
class inversion so what we have is a
white middle class that has been largely
excluded as a result of globalization
and globalism from participation in the
economy and they basically said
like in the movie we're mad as hell and
we're not going to take it anymore but
I'm
I'm Professor Bobby it's sweet to have
you I don't know how much you heard of
what was said before
that just come in good I'm gonna assume
you see nothing
um we're looking for an explanation for
this election which not many some but
not many uh called right in advance
we've talked about the perceived
deficiencies of Hillary Clinton and
maybe that was part of it and then uh
We've also heard that just it was a
change year and in a change year the
pendulum was going to swing away from
Democrats to towards Republicans what is
your own explanation for why this
outcome came about
well it's certainly true that uh
all political societies uh have more
values than they can realize and so they
bring to a temporary preeminence one
party and then after four eight years
they shift gears and bringing another
party to support different values
there's a pattern of that that's partly
I think
an explanation but I think the broader
picture is that this is the change
happening all across the industrial and
post-industrialized societies
it is a change as the kind of state we
have had
in the U.S since the 1860s and Europe
since the 1870s has begun to very
rapidly Decay with the end of the long
Wars the 20th century and the reaction
of
groups that were linked to that state
industrial groups National groups
because each of these industrial nation
states favored a particular sort of
ethnic and political group
that reaction is playing out all across
the democracies
I want to put this to you then Steve
Hilton if you can hear us yeah um this
is this idea that there was a common
pattern here brexit then Trump the
phrase used now perhaps overused about
those who are left behind uh and that
this is really about some of those
bigger forces that Philip Bobbitt was
perhaps describing and a response to
globalization Etc just sketch out for us
if you think that is what was going on
in this election
um I think that's certainly a big part
of it but it's not the only thing I
think that um
really I think it's important to look at
the election not just in I know that the
the theme of most of our discussion is
going to be Trump but I think it's
important to look at it in the context
of the the whole election because of
course the Republicans won not just the
presidency but the Senate and the house
and state legislatures across the
country and Governor's races it was a
really big defeat for Democrats in
general not just Hillary Clinton and I
think that what that tells you is that
this was a repudiation a big repudiation
of of the Obama years and I think in in
two particular ways
um and the first is actually Beyond just
Obama and that's where I agree about
this General point on globalization
I think the economic explanation is
pretty fundamental for me the most
telling
statistic the most telling data point
that explains more than anything else
about what happened as Stacy touched on
this earlier is that
despite incomes in America uh happily
increasing in the last 12 months that
that uh that came out during the
campaign in about September if you look
at the long run picture the median
household income in America today is
lower than it was in 1999. I think that
has two uh aspects to it first of all
the straightforward economical which is
the people now that's half of America
half of American households earning less
than than uh before Bush began his
presidency and Obama so they've had
eight years of bush eight years of Obama
and throughout all of that incomes are
down while the rich have got richer and
I think that explains not just their
sense of economic frustration but
political frustration too because the
sense is that it doesn't matter who you
vote for it doesn't matter whether you
have Republicans at the White House Or
democrats you know literally the rich
get richer we get poorer and so that's
what I think explains that sense of
desperation it says look we're going to
vote for Trump despite all his obvious
flaws as an individual and as a
candidate and so on because they're just
looking for something that will change
this but I do think there's one other
aspect to this that I think it's
important to bear in mind and I think
this is probably
particularly a U.S aspect rather than
the global one and that is this very
strong sense I think on the part of a
lot of people of being really not just
left behind economically but but really
condescended to and spoken down to by
the people they perceive to be running
the economy and running government and I
think the moment that really
crystallized that and I thought was the
moment when I thought that Hillary
Clinton was bound to lose was her speech
about the basket of deplorables where
she really revealed the attitude that I
think a lot of people in in the
heartland of America working people
sense that they are viewed by the
coastal Elites as being inferior not
culturally up to the mark and so on and
I think that that cultural aspect of it
was really important well that goes
nicely to um Applebaum because you've
written some uh some things in these
areas and talked about this that it
isn't just about economics there's a
cultural Dimension to this yeah I mean
hard to pin
depend why everybody he voted for what
reason there are many reasons but I
think a lot of the economic explanations
have been pretty superficial if you look
at how the voting went you know actually
the poorest Americans and this is all
across including in for example in Texas
which is a red State the poorest
Americans voted for Hillary Clinton so
we're not talking about exactly it's not
like the poor rose up and overthrew the
rich it's a much more complicated
problem I also think that there's not
enough attention has been paid to how
Trump ran his campaign and the language
that he was using to attract people he
really he also created a kind of us and
them very much like authoritarian
leaders do we The Real Americans against
the fake Americans and he created a
sense of identity around a group that
hadn't I mean I suppose it's been
appealed to like that before but not in
quite a clear not quite as aggressive
away and he appealed to them almost as
if he were a in the way that say you
know a European nationalist appeals to
his own Nation you know you know the
Dutch to Dutch people you know we need
to be more Dutch and this was really a
very make America great again has an
element of nostalgia to it as well you
know that it's a kind of bringing back
the real America and I think that
um at a time when politics are
incredibly
um uh seem very distant from people and
they seem very you know in a world where
you can do all kinds of things very
quickly you know you can order something
online and click a button and get it
delivered the next day and you can like
something and feel like you've made a
statement
um politics seems very complicated it
takes a long time democracy is very
boring it's very frustrating
and Trump seemed to offer some kind of
instant Solutions in a very classic
populist sort of magical thinking I will
fix it I will make things great again
and he appealed to the cultural identity
of of a part of it and I think that was
part of what he wanted just to take
further the point you made about
European populist figures some people
have said said in response to the kind
of argument Steve Hilton was making
about economics they've said look don't
underestimate the extent to which this
was a nativist appeal loaded with with
racial resentment because he was saying
and people said make America great again
means make America white again and there
was this element about gender it was a
female candidate and people have said
that you know that you can't you cannot
exclude that from the picture just just
I very much don't want to say that
everybody who voted for Trump is a
racist I'm not saying that but I think
there was an element of
um you know we've had this black
president we have this woman can you
know let's have one of us again you know
let's bring back
um somebody who is familiar somebody who
belongs in the familiar hierarchy let's
get back to where we were before and to
a lot of people that had a subconscious
or conscious appeal and by the way you
could see it you know if he didn't say
it exactly you could absolutely see it
on social media I mean the the racism
the anti-Semitism and the misogyny of
his supporters was something I have
never seen before in American politics
ever and there was a lot of it and it
was all the time and everybody who who
interacted it all online saw it and so
that can't be eliminated as an issue we
should let you have a response just on
that point
so there's an ALT left as well as an
alt-right and the political spectrum is
a very wide spectrum it is in the United
States it is in European countries uh I
think that Trump is really very much a
center-right politician not a far right
politician by any means already bringing
people into his administration what
would you have to do for you to describe
him as Farah
he'd have to prove that he was an
authoritarian
in terms of actions rather than just
with exactly we're going to get back
into all this I'm sure but um Jamie
let's go to you on on on what now in a
way we've we talked up to November the
8th
November the 8th to November 30th we've
had 22 days of him being president-elect
Trump what have we seen what have we
learned what little Clues have we got
into first of all just let me thank you
for excusing me from the explanation
part of the discussion because it would
be too painful
um
look uh there's a couple of things that
I think you can see already
in the domestic area we have
seen the president-elect suggest in a
meeting with the New York Times that
maybe his actions on Obamacare won't be
so
drastic and then higher as the uh or
proposed as the Secretary of Health and
Human Services the single most opponent
of Obamacare so I think we're seeing
that going back and forth and we'll just
have to see how that comes about I tend
to do foreign policy I'll stick with
that except I I can't help but throw in
that that it looks like Donald Trump
will be the least Rich member of his
cabinet because he's hired only
billionaires for the uh domestic area
and that's not a comment about what his
real wealth is it's just a comment about
how rich these people are working for a
Dollar by the way right they don't need
the money you're absolutely right
um
the um
on Foreign Affairs where I actually know
some of the individuals involved
I don't know whether you call it
alt-right or extreme right or way on the
right it would be hard to find
to more extreme right-wing people who
will spend the most time all day long
with Donald Trump particularly
the National Security advisor General
Flynn who holds views that were deemed
so unusual
by the military and the intelligence
community that he was essentially pushed
out of his job it ended up being called
a management issue when he was the
director of the defense intelligence
agency but basically he was so out of
sync with the mainstream of the National
Security bureaucracy not the Obama Obama
let me just have my speak and you can
please jump in we're talking about an
Obama administration where the National
Security bureaucracy not the president
the National Security bureaucracy asked
him to go but president had nothing to
do with it these were Generals these
were uh the the heads of the uh the
National Intelligence Community thought
General Flynn was just too aggressive
they had things called Flynn facts which
were wild unusual things today's New
York Times gives you an example of where
General Flynn believes
not only the one you've heard that
radical Islam is a is is is the
explanation Islam is more of an
explanation than the radicalization of
Youth that's the way he would put it and
you know he's entitled to that view but
he's regarded George Bush as having not
sufficiently focused on Islam this is
General Flynn regards former President
Bush as missing the point when he went
to a mosque and tried to say that Islam
is not the problem it's a small
percentage that's not Obama That's
President Bush that he regarded as as
insufficiently anti-islamic for him but
the real kicker came out today which is
that General Flynn believes and I am not
exaggerating that the radical Islamic
groups like Al Qaeda and others are
linked up with China and North Korea
and that there is an axis of China North
Korea and radical Islam that poses a
threat to the United States if you don't
believe me please look at today's New
York Times there's a very clear
description of what's in his book and I
urge you to read it if you think I'm
exaggerating so all I would say is that
there it's very hard to know what
Trump's foreign policy is going to be
the only thread that holds it together
the only one I can see is a an extreme
approach to the terrorist
counterterrorism Problem by focusing
more on the religion than the Obama and
Bush administrations did and roughly the
same on the counterterrorism classic
approach we thank you we're essentially
going to talk about foreign policy more
and we're going to move on to that just
in terms of these 22 days what they
revealed the manner the style the way
the appointments are being made very
very very briefly I want to hear from
Mary this is easy
it's a very unusual time in our lives
when the president of the United States
goes on his Tweeter or Twitter or
whatever I'm not very good at this and
says that millions of people were
fraudulently voted
which is a lie
and then when CNN and and see if you can
remember the last time this happened
says that these claims are baseless
he tweets back you prove it's not true
when's the last time we heard that
do you want to come back on that very
equivalent then we're going to get you
married
Ted why don't you just come back just on
this point about the Tweet about the
million Trump claiming the millions
voted fraudulent well just on that the
source is Clinton News Network as we
call it in the United States which is a
total cooperation with the Democratic
party so who's to know what to believe I
mean the fact is and we'll see this more
and more evidence when you know when the
not the research is done but when the
empirical evidence is brought forward
that a lot of illegal immigrants voted
in this election because they couldn't
prove uh that they had the right to vote
or not to vote I mean it's an ongoing
problem in American politics
to Steve just because you're there are
you comfortable with this kind of talk
you've you've been pretty supportive in
your public comments of the Trump
election hearing these claims millions
of fraudulent voters I'm not and I but I
I have a slightly different take to
Jamie uh which is I don't really take it
seriously
um I think that
fundamentally we've over the last 18
months I think we've all understood that
that there are aspects of Trump's
Behavior
that no one could support
um including his supporters that's not
why they voted for him and so I I'm not
at all surprised that some aspects of
that behavior are continuing even though
others are clearly being moderated
um and for me I'm long past the point of
being outraged by or shocked or
surprised by anything he does of that
kind and I think the real question is
will he deliver on the core promises he
made particularly of getting growth up
bringing jobs back raising people's
incomes in the end that's what he's got
to do and all this other stuff I think
is you know it may be unattractive it
may be disrespectful to the Constitution
and so on but in the end I think you
know we've we've passed the point of
needing to care about that I mean
because what at the sense I'm getting
from a couple of colleagues here is it
was fine to not take him seriously when
he wasn't the president-elect of the
United States that's the point he's now
the president he's now about to be the
president so don't you just have to
start taking it seriously no no you have
to take seriously is the problem the
real world problems that he's going to
have to deal with which is falling
incomes low labor participation rates a
terror Threat all of these are real
things and the right way to judge him is
how he handles those real things okay
not whether he's tweeting and having an
exchange with CNN